the following is the story about the man
who changed everything
the man who was born at just the right
time with just the right mix of stuff
the man who found the edge of the
universe this man's name was Simon
Farlander he was born about 400 years
ago back in the year 2012 a strange time
when humanity and Technology began to
rapidly merge and things started to
change in ways that couldn't yet even be
understood in Simon's early life he was
an incredible child many years ahead of
his peers intellectually he showed signs
of genius and it was clear that he had
something special
something that allowed him to understand
complex equations and ideas quickly and
clearly unlike most other children and
even many adults for that matter
although Simon was treated somewhat
uniquely as a result of his advanced
intelligence he still had a nice
ordinary early childhood his parents
treated him how any young boy should be
treated and Simon and his parents were
extremely close they would go out and
explore the world together and made
efforts to ensure that Simon felt normal
yet engaged in his intellect however at
the age of 8 something horrible happened
to Simon one of those moments that
completely alters the course of one's
life a moment where the curtains pull
back a tiny bit more than they should
for where you are sitting and reveal
something that forever changes your
perspective on the show of life at the
age of 8 Simon's mother contracted a
rare stomach virus on an overseas
business trip over the course of the
preceding several weeks
Simon watched his mother lose all of her
body weight while doctors frantically
tried to figure out what was wrong with
her and how to fix it as time waned and
doctors efforts continually fell short
Simon's solely watched his mother lose
her soul right in front of Simon's eyes
his mother died when his mother passed
Simon looked to his father and asked
where does mom go now his father
responded well she's in a better place
now she's in heaven being inquisitive
and intelligent young boy that Simon was
he asked but what's heaven and how is it
better than being here with us
well it's peaceful it's somewhere way up
in the sky past everything somewhere
right at the edge of the universe
responded Simon's father and Simon's
youthful optimism he took this very
literally he believed that this edge of
the universe was a real place that if he
could find it he would find his mother
how could it not be real after all his
father told him it was so it must be and
so Simon decided in this moment that he
would find it
Simon grew older he began to mature as
intelligence began to form more lucidly
he would soon realize that no one
including his father had any real clue
as to what they were talking about that
no one knew what was going on who anyone
was where anyone came from or where
anyone was going Simon found this lack
of understanding and fury ating how
could no one know what was going on how
could even his own father make such
claims how could everyone just act like
they had it all under control and make
stuff up to try and cope with the fact
that no one really does someone refused
to accept this someone refused to play
along with the ruse instead of being
like most children when they turn into
young adults and let their youthful
hopes and dreams die the dream Simon had
about finding the edge of the universe
was a dream he continued to sustain only
now he refined it and pursued it
intellectually he made it his life's
mission to research and understand the
conditions of the universe in the
meaning of life to find out what all of
this nonsense was about to see if his
mother was still out there somewhere
Simon would embark on a career in
physical cosmology a field concern
entirely with the structure and dynamic
of the universe its source and its
ultimate fate this undertaking deeply
excited Simon they got him up early
every day and kept them up late every
night through his late teens and early
20s his enthusiasm combined with his
blossoming genius got him into an Ivy
League college and an amazing ph.d
program
after completing college Simon went on
to join a major leading research
organization every step along the way
through school and his career Simon
would learn a little bit more about the
laws and theories of the universe every
step made Simon feel a little more
hopeful and excited hopeful and excited
that there was something new and
incredible to be discovered by the Year
2043 Simon had worked his way up into a
lead role in the research organization
at this time the company was developing
a mission to the planet Mars with the
intent to create the first ever
interplanetary research group based on
another planet surface
Simon was assigned the lead of this
mission for Simon this adventure yet
again rejuvenated his hopefulness and
excitement for life the idea that he
would be one step closer to the edge of
the universe one step closer to touching
more truth this kept the fire burning
inside of him once on Mars
Simon led the research team that would
mine the landscape seeking discoveries
and looking for resources that could be
of practical and theoretical used to
human life as more and more time would
pass Simon who proved to be an
incredibly successful leader and was
responsible for many discoveries that
dramatically benefit
humanity Simon's hopefulness intrigue
and success became a major factor in
humanity's inspiration to continue
forward into the cosmos and explore
several other new planets thereafter
soon humanity would begin to travel
deeper and deeper into the unknown every
step in every discovery along the way
would reveal a little bit more about
reality and constantly renew Simon's
excitement and hope like blindly putting
our hand into a box without knowing
what's inside the deeper and deeper
humanity reached the further the
anticipation and excitement built but
the question remained how far could we
reach what was at the bottom of this box
with the longer life expectancy than
ever before as a result of new
technology and medical treatments
Simon's ability to maintain intellectual
momentum and continue leading humanity
further into the cosmos exceeded far
beyond any possibility of the past and
Simon wasn't going to stop over the next
many years Simon would go on to become
the most intelligent innovative and
profound individuals to ever cross
humanity a super genius as Semite column
as technological theoretical and medical
advancements compounded even further
humanity's understanding about the
universe unfolded more and more all the
way up until humanity became a type 3
civilization a civilization that
possesses the knowledge of how to use
and control energy at the scale of its
entire host galaxy and it was of course
one of Simon's discoveries that allowed
this to happen in the year 2330 Simon
discovered a method of using a galactic
nucleus named blazar as an energy source
which would bring humanity into type 3
and provided with interstellar and
interdimensional travel capabilities
Simon would become a sort of supreme
leader in this new order of the universe
determining the places humanity would go
and what it would acquire build and use
within the universe and most importantly
the Simon for the first time he now had
the ability of finding if it existed the
very edge of the universe some more
years passed and some would find himself
on the furthest planet in the furthest
galaxy away from Earth ever inhabited by
human while on this planet you noticed
something in the distance
a strange wall of light unlike anything
he had ever seen before
dissimilar from the isolated light of a
star or a black hole this light appeared
more like a blanket covering the entire
viewable space in its direction a wall
were the empty darkness of space met
parallel with an intense pure white
light
Simon pounded with excitement and hope
for what it might be after probing the
wall and finding no retrievable data for
what
might be on the other side it was
determined that it was significantly
risky to travel up to it Simon decided
to do it anyway after all he did not
make it this far by not taking risks for
the sake of his curiosity and excitement
Simon took off towards the wall as he
got closer and closer the reality of
this situation began to overwhelm him he
knew fairly well based on his research
and understanding that if there was an
edge to the universe it would have
certain characteristics and this
appeared to have them as he approached
the light became more and more intense
Simon arrived at the face of the wall
the light nearly searing his eyes he
reached out to touch it it was hard like
a glowing concrete wall with no give and
no apparent entry
Simon looked in all directions along the
wall it went on for as far as the sight
would allow him to see in this moment he
realized this was it he had found it the
source of all meaning the place where we
all come from in the place where we all
end up the edge of the universe and
Simon realizes that it's nothing just
the end not peaceful but not not
peaceful either just nothing suddenly
Simon loses all of his excitement all of
his hope the end of the game
Simon won but just like the video games
he played as a child the prize was
nothing more than a completed game disc
he no longer had any interest in Simon
realized how foolish she was and that
the whole time it wasn't the source of
all meaning that he was chasing it
wasn't the edge of the universe
it wasn't heaven it wasn't even his
mother it was hope he was merely chasing
having something to chase a game to play
something to strive for but just like a
dog chasing its tail what he wanted he
had all along the way for an initial
moment this devastated Simon but then he
was happy Simon returned back to the
civilization of humanity that was
eagerly awaiting his return to hear news
about what the wall of light was when
Simon returned they asked with great
anticipation is it the edge of the
universe is it heaven is it the source
of everything
Simon looked at the crowd and thought to
himself for a moment then he said no it
was
thing just a strange light reflection
phenomenon nothing to be concerned about
disappointed that the edge of the
universe and the source of all meaning
had still not been discovered humanity
continued to look elsewhere excited and
hopeful that one day maybe they would
find it thank you for watching if he
found enjoyment and value in this video
please give it a thumbs up share your
thoughts in the comments below and if
you are not already be sure to subscribe
to our Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder
[Music]